[Musique]
cette diplômée de l'école des hautes
études commerciales de montréal a bien
sûr dans les idées son mémoire de
maîtrise entre 2015 et 2017
elle l'a produit sur l'industrie du
skateboard cette étudiante modèle a fait
ses devoirs et aujourd'hui sur sa
planche à roulettes
annie gourgue l'ia est prêt à se
qualifier pour la première épreuve de
skateboard les jeux olympiques angers
quand j'ai reçu la bourse pour faire mon
mémoire y avait une cérémonie lui
disaient les petites db mémoire les
personnes qui avaient reçu des bourses
puis quand le mien a pas répondu c'est
horrible y'avait personne n'est mieux
placé que moi pour faire un mémoire de
maîtrise sur l'industrie du disque est
de savoir ce qui est quand même une
sculpture qui est très rebelle tu veux
pas je suis un peu cliché dire ça mais
c'est vrai que ça lien la rue mixer
série
mon mémoire s'intitule on n'est pas là
pour faire de l'argent c'est une analyse
du disco des gestionnaires dans les
puces quais bordant la mairie dion au
niveau des participants y avait plein de
questions qui fait vraiment contre la
rue des olympiques
c'est ce qui est vraiment allumé pour
moi pour mon sujet maîtrise quand j'ai
fait ma collègue de données je parte en
californie univers j'ai fait j'ai fait
ma collègue de même la boxe c'est là où
j'ai retenu que par la compétition qui
s'est logée tahiti où etienne pour la
première fois ci c'est comme ça que ça
déboule et toute l'histoire à
l'imprimante en mémoire comme il est
jusqu'à présent le rêve olympique de la
rebelle des hec et bien vivant
championne canadienne de street à miglia
occupe le 18e rang mondial de la
discipline
les 20 premières seront qualifiées pour
les jeux de tokyo
à 28 ans il a pris voir ce nouveau mode
de vie n'avait jamais utilisé le terme
athlètes pour parler de moi
environ deux ans je n'étais vraiment pas
pour moi je n'avais jamais le dos des
plus beaux souvenirs de son parcours
c'est ce voyage au mexique avec l'esc
bordeaux s'il ya une dizaine d'années
des filles de montréal prête à tout pour
populariser leur sport bien avant
l'adhésion au programme olympique fait
de l'international aujourd'hui montréal
les gens parlent de montréal comme de
nouvelles où il ya beaucoup de filles
font du skate et annie la plus jeune de
ce groupe est devenu aujourd'hui l'un
des plus grandes ambassadrices tout ce
qui est beau j'entends son poirier
radio-canada maury